[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon mari est un ingénieur raté profil
matin il faisait des factorielle en cm1
avec son ami d'enfance les factorielle
je ne sais pas ce que c'est mais c'est
un programme de terminale
catalogué bon en maths si naturellement
que la remontée vers la filière
ingénieur après le bac
parce que je cite tu gagneras plein
d'argent et tu trouvera bien un domaine
qui t'intéresse déjà à ce moment il
avait l'intuition que ce n'était pas
forcément le bon parcours pour lui
antoine a fait son maximum pour se faire
éjecter
mais il n'a pas eu le courage d'être
assez mauvais et l'a finalement obtenu
son sésame 1 à bac + 5
il a rejoint le labo de recherche d'un
grand groupe de télécoms à paris le
genre d'entreprise avec management à
l'américaine si c'est une entreprise
attractive avec un baby foot
aux yeux de la société c'était la
réussite
le prestige pour ma part j'ai une
scolarité normale
j'ai toujours eu des capacités que
j'attribue au fait qu'il y avait un
adulte derrière moi pour ne pas dire sur
mon dos pour vérifier si mes devoirs et
ai fait mes notes étaient bonnes mais
leçons ont été apprises et pourtant ce
que je retiens de toutes ces années peut
se résumer en une phrase qu'est-ce que
je me suis ennuyé j'avais un profond
désintérêt pour au choix soit ce que
nous nous enseignait soit la manière
dont on nous l'apprenez je n'ai
véritablement pas de souvenir de l'école
à part peut-être cette fois qui m'a
vraiment marqué j'ai 8 ans madame lise
débarque dans nos classes avec
un énorme poumon de boeuf et une paille
et à l'aide de cette paille elle s'est
mise à gonfler et dégonfler ce poumon
sous nos yeux médusés des moments
passionnants comme celui là je peux les
compter sur les doigts d'une main avec
nos parcours respectifs
antoine et moi avons cherché des
alternatives à l'école on s'est rendu
compte qu'elle n'était pas obligatoire
on a entendu parler de la pédagogie
montessori de l'instruction en famille
et puis on est arrivé en nouvelle
calédonie et on a emménagé à côté d'une
école démocratique
ce terme ne vous dit peut-être pas
grand-chose comme ce fut le cas pour moi
il ya encore deux ans les rares
reportage généralistes sur le sujet la
définit systématiquement comme une école
où il n'y a ni cours mon professeur ni
de voir ni notes etc
et je trouve que c'est réducteur de
définir quelque chose parce qu'il n'est
pas ou ce qu'il ne fait pas mais je vous
avoue que je n'ai pas trouvé de
définition plus parlante et synthétique
alors je vous propose que pour ce soir
on part sur cette définition de base
je rajouterais même que c'est une école
où il n'ya pas de récréation ce que je
ne vous ai pas raconté
c'est que malgré mon parcours scolaire
peu stimulant j'ai eu la chance
contrairement antoine de trouver un
parcours professionnel qui me passionne
je travaille dans l'audiovisuel et je
suis amené à réaliser des films de
communication notamment
et c'est avec cette casquette que j'ai
été accueilli la première fois dans
cette école particulière
l'école dont je vais vous parler ce soir
s'appelle la petite école qui regarde la
montagne
elle est située à d'un béart nouvelle
calédonie et concrètement c'est une
maison avec un jardin
mais c'est surtout un lieu de vie pour
les enfants et un endroit où ils sont
libres de leur apprentissage et libre du
temps qu'ils y consacrent le premier
matin je suis allé filmer
il y avait un atelier mousse au chocolat
qui était proposé cet atelier mousse au
chocolat
proposé par une fête une petite fille de
7 ans un groupe d'enfants entre trois et
cinq ans la mousse au chocolat
petit rappel il faut casser des oeufs
séparez les blancs des jaunes monter les
blancs en neige
ces techniques clairement je vous
rappelle que les enfants entre 3 et 5
ans il n'y a aucun adulte avec amélie
ils ont tous manipulés
amélie leur a montré plusieurs
techniques pour séparer le blanc des
jaunes que même moi je ne connaissais
pas alors je vous avoue que cette
technique manuelle
je ne suis pas sûr de la réutiliser mais
elle a au moins le mérite d'exister
là je voudrais vous montrer la tête et
les yeux de nathan quand il regarde une
des techniques d'amélie
je ne sais pas vous mais moi c'est cette
tête là que j'ai envie de voir sur le
visage de mon enfant le plus souvent
possible parce qu'un enfant qui fait sa
tête avec un tel niveau d'absorption et
de concentration c'est un milliard de
neurones qui sont en train se connecter
bon ce chiffre de 1 milliard de neurones
ne repose sur aucune étude scientifique
c'est une vulgaire approximations en
revanche voici un vrai chiffre dans le
cerveau de l'enfant avant cinq ans il y
as entre 700 et 1000 connexions
neuronales par seconde
je ne sais pas combien de connexions
neuronales il ya eu quand ils ont
commencé à goûter au chocolat fondu
mais vu leur enthousiasme
ça devait être beaucoup j'ai aussi filmé
deux enfants qui avaient pris
l'initiative de construire une cabane
avec des modules de gymnastique si vous
pensez que ces enfants s'amusent
c'est parce qu'à l'école démocratique le
travail n'est pas séparée du récréatif
c'était intéressant dès le début puisque
avant même d'avoir posé le premier
module jalil le petit garçon
conceptualisé ce qu'il allait faire
il avait déjà une stratégie et lens
départ à son amie sarah alors dans les
faits ça s'est pas vraiment passé comme
il avait prévu
il ya eu quelques petites erreurs de
chantier ils ont essayé de monter un mur
sur une base cylindrique c'était pas
évident un moment ils ont aussi monté un
mur juste derrière la porte quand ça
marchait pas d'un point de vue de
l'adulte les enfants ont vécu plusieurs
échecs mais le fait que personne ne soit
là pour souligner leurs erreurs leurs
faire une remarque même bienveillante
leur donner un conseil ou leur dire
comment ne pas se tromper c'est que les
erreurs de jalil et sarah n'ont eu
aucune conséquence émotionnel ça
et partie de l'activité il fallait juste
réfléchir différemment tester une autre
solution
ils ne se sont pas découragés leur
enthousiasme est restée intacte et à la
fin ils ont totalement atteint leur
objectif
[Musique]
voilà il avait une cabane avec quatre
murs un toit une porte et cette cabane
pouvait accueillir exactement deux
enfants à l'école démocratique
l'échec fait partie du processus
d'apprentissage et 10,1 me disais je
n'ai pas échoué
j'ai trouvé dix mille solutions qui ne
fonctionnait pas c'est important de
comprendre que l'école démocratique
n'est pas une pédagogie les pédagogies
sont des outils l'école démocratique est
un système pour bien remettre les choses
en perspective dans une école
démocratique
on propose des pédagogies comme la
pédagogie montessori freiner ou steiner
en fait tout ce qu'il ya un intérêt pour
le développement du potentiel de
l'enfant à sa place dans une école
démocratique
tout est prétexte pour apprendre il n'a
pas de discipline prestigieuses ou
valoriser les enfants sont libres de
leurs apprentissages libre de la manière
dont ils apprennent et parfois même on
ne sait pas comment ils apprennent et ça
ça peut être valable pour des savoirs
fondamentaux comme la lecture mais à
quoi sert l'école
la fonction principale de l'école est
d'offrir à tous les enfants qui la
fréquentent un environnement riche c'est
à dire en environnement il ya beaucoup
de matériel des ressources des
intervenants la littérature tout cela en
libre accès et pour tim hull et la
curiosité des enfants mais aussi pour
nourrir cette curiosité en aucun cas
contrairement à une idée reçue en aucun
cas les enfants ne sont laissés livrés à
eux mêmes ils ont un cadre et ils sont
libres dans ce cadre alors tout cela a
été des notions un peu longue à
assimiler pour moi qui n'avait connu
qu'un système scolaire rigide
l'hiérarchie zh et compétitif mais
revenons à jalil et sarah
[Musique]
pendant qu'ils construisaient leur
cabane on le voit sur ces images il
sautait dans tous les sens il courait il
régnait il chantait il se racontait des
blagues
il est des galipettes on pourrait
facilement dire que ces enfants sont
dissipés et pourtant leur agitation ne
les a jamais détourner de leur activité
de construction
quand je vois ces images je me replonge
dans mes souvenirs d'école et je repense
à toutes ces heures passées derrière un
bureau sans avoir le droit ni parler ni
de me déplacer ni même de trop bouger
qui parmi vous a vécu cette scolarité je
vois plein de doigts qui se lève nous
sommes nombreux dans ce cas mais combien
sommes nous à questionner et remettre en
cause ses pratiques
quand j'étais plus jeune on avait le
droit de temps en temps à une heure de
cours de citoyenneté et je n'y
comprenais pas grand-chose à l'âge
adulte
j'ai compris pourquoi je ne comprenais
pas la citoyenneté n'est pas une
discipline qui s'enseigne c'est plutôt
un mode de gouvernance qui se pratique
ça l'école démocratique l'a bien compris
et c'est la raison pour laquelle elle
s'organise comme une petite société il
ya des conseils d'école des propositions
des porteurs de projets des débats des
votes
la voix d'un enfant compte et est
entendu au même titre que celle d'un
adulte
les décisions sont prises en commun et
peuvent être remises en cause et
redébattu en fonction des arguments ou
des événements un exemple à l'école les
enfants un trampoline et la
problématique a vite été identifiés pour
des raisons de sécurité et de confort il
a fallu limiter le nombre d'usagers sur
ce trampoline après avoir établi
quelques règles les enfants se sont
rendus compte que
en fonction de l'âge des usagers on
pouvait mettre plus enfant plus jeune et
moins du groupe des grands alors ils ont
remis en cause et redébattu leurs
propres règles pour apporter de la
nuance à la petite école qui regarde la
montagne
la communication est une compétence
transmise au quotidien les personnes qui
s'occupent des enfants sont toutes
formes et à la communication non
violente
il a beaucoup d'outils et de techniques
qui sont utilisés est proposé aux
enfants la gestion des émotions
la médiation les temps de parole la
recherche de solutions la gestion des
conflits
le consentement le consentement
c'est d'ailleurs frappant entendre une
conversation entre deux petites filles
de 3 ans beaucoup de leurs phrases
commencent par tes ok pour un thé hockey
pour que je prenne ta poupée et moi je
te prête mon doudou ou de constater
qu'un enfant de 5 ans c'est déjà nuancé
ses émotions devant une expression de
colère jeudi à l'enfant je vois de la
colère chez toi lui peut me répondre non
je suis indigné non je suis frustré non
je suis irrité
vous savez pourquoi ça m'impressionne
parce que je me rends compte que ce sont
des compétences que moi je n'ai pas un
travaillant sur cette conférence
je me suis rendu compte que si l'école
démocratique était d'adapter pour un
grand nombre d'enfants
elles ne l'étaient en revanche pas pour
tous les parents la liberté vous l'aurez
compris est le mot d'ordre à l'école
démocratique et laissés libres son
enfant veut dire que l'on a travaillé
sur ces peurs que l'on a compris
l'intérêt du jeu libre nos structures et
que l'on a désacralisé les savoirs
académiques que l'on a renoncé à ses
attentes à court moyen et long termes
sur les apprentissages de son enfant et
qu'on lui fait confiance dans sa manière
d'être lui-même
les parents des enfants qui vont dans
des écoles démocratique ont le point
commun d'oser sortir des sentiers battus
laurent gay
on va au delà d'un regard critique ils
sont dans l'action
beaucoup font le choix pour ne pas dire
le sacrifice financier de payer 7
coloris t qui ne reçoit aucune
subvention à la petite école qui regarde
la montagne on pense que tous les
citoyens devraient pouvoir choisir
l'éducation qu'ils veulent pour leurs
enfants et c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'école cherche des solutions pour
devenir la première école démocratique
gratuite
une autre ambition de l'école de venir
dès la rentrée prochaine
zéro déchet quand on parle des écoles
démocratique
les gens sont souvent perplexes voire
méfiants et je comprends qu'ils aient
cette réaction
l'esprit critique est une démarche saine
est essentielle mais pour moi l'école
démocratique n'a rien à prouver
ce n'est pas parce que ce n'est pas
connue que ces nouveaux tout hélas pas
en nouvelle calédonie mais à travers le
monde des écoles démocratique
il en existe depuis une centaine
d'années en angleterre c'est l'école se
meurt il est aux états unis le réseau
des écoles sudbury à plus d'une
cinquantaine d'années d'existence des
enfants sont passés dans ces écoles y
ont grandi sont devenus des adultes qui
ont témoigné les fondateurs de ces
écoles comme daniel greenberg ou
alexander neil ont écrit des ouvrages
pour relater leurs expériences et leurs
observations que chacun peut consulter
ce que je comprends moins en revanche
c'est que les personnes critiques
vis-à-vis de ces écoles et émergentes
n'est pas la même démarche et les mêmes
exigences vis-à-vis de l'école où
eux-mêmes sont allés et ils vont
peut-être leurs enfants j'ai posé la
question à antoine que serais tu devenu
si tu avais pu fréquenter une école où
tu aurais été libres 2 étapes de thé
apprentissage sa réponse
j'aurais eu une carrière de joueur de
poker sur internet
est-ce que ça ce serait véritablement
passé est ce que ce n'est qu'un fantasme
on ne sera jamais ce qui s'est passé en
vrai pour antoine c'est qu'à 27 ans il a
repris des études quand il quand on a eu
notre premier enfant il était encore
étudiant
aujourd'hui il est kiné paquin et raté
qui n'est content nous avons deux
enfants donc et en tant que parents nous
souhaitons à nos enfants qu'ils aient
une motivation intrinsèque
vous savez c'est cette motivation qui
vous fait faire des choses pas pour
avoir une bonne note pas pour être
meilleur que le voisin pas pour que
l'adulte vous récompense ou vous aime
mais parce que c'est un besoin qui vous
appartient et que vous nourrissez on
souhaite à nos enfants qu'ils conservent
intact leur curiosité naturelle et leur
enthousiasme le plus longtemps possible
parce que l'on pense que c'est un moteur
puissant dans le développement de l'être
on souhaite à nos enfants qu'ils aient
une connaissance d'eux-mêmes et de leur
potentiel
parce que l'on pense que c'est une clé
pour être heureux en tant que parent on
a envie de voir grandir nos enfants au
contact de la nature et parce qu'on les
aime très fort mais aussi parce que on
n'a pas envie qu'ils deviennent des
ingénieurs raté mais surtout parce qu'on
les aime très fort on veut leur faire ce
cadeau d'une enfance libre
[Applaudissements]